Peggy 18
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone and welcome to the first
ever Rainbow six siege live stream we
are live from the Montreal Ubisoft
Studios I am Jen the community developer
on Rainbow six siege and I am joined
today by Andrew whips game designer can
you tell us a little bit more about what
you do to start things off yeah I'm a
game designer on all the weapons gadgets
and the destruction gameplay alright so
today we're gonna be bringing to you
guys the hole III experience that we did
behind closed doors at e3 that we showed
to the journalists so we're gonna be
kicking things off with the presentation
I was doing in the boot followed by live
gameplay for you guys 5 vs. 5
multiplayer action and then we will also
be taking your questions from Twitter so
make sure to start sending them to us at
hashtag Rainbow six live and we will be
taking them from there and if you do
submit a question you're entering for a
chance to win some sweet swag we have
some Rainbow six caps for you as well as
submarine will six search shirts so you
can rock them like we do alright so
let's get started with the Rainbow six
siege III presentation so basically when
we started Rainbow six siege we decided
to put multiplayer first because we
wanted to make sure to provide to our
players are really tight gameplay
experience to make Rainbow six siege we
asked yourself what is Rainbow six well
at its core it's a team-based tactical
shooter set in an indoor environment on
one side we have the rainbows leading
the assaults and on the other side we
have the enemies countering the assaults
in the middle we have a wall and it is
around that wall that we focused in
siege and it is around that wall that we
extended from now on the wall is a
fortress and from now on both sides are
aware of each other and of the incoming
confrontation the enemies are going to
be able to create a stronghold
they will have tools and time to prepare
for it they're going to be able to
barricade trap and surveil their
territory and on the other side the
rainbows will also come prepared they
will be able to observe the fortified
area try to find a weak point try to
locate the objective location
establish a plan and then try to break
into the stronghold our siege is a
battle between certification and
reaching and it is with breaching in
mind that we came to our big break
through destruction with our new real
blast destruction technology made
entirely at the Ubisoft Montreal studios
our players are going to be able to use
destruction in a meaningful way in order
to gain a tactical edge and they're
going to be able to get real creative
with it
so speaking of players today we're gonna
be having a live demo for you guys and I
know you're really excited about it I
hope so haha so basically what we're
gonna be starting things off with is to
demo rounds that are more scripted
because we want to make sure that you
get the full experience you get to see
our features you get to know basically
what our game is about it's a good
introduction to it and then we will be
playing sixth-round no guidelines free
for well that's free for all but
everyone's gonna be playing to win it
and that's basically what we're gonna be
doing today Andrew can you tell us a
little bit about the game rules
applicable to our us to dress cute game
modes yeah so it's a five versus five
hostage-rescue game mode no respawn are
we on the attacking side the attackers
they need to get a break into the enemy
vme stronghold and escort the hostage to
safety outside and on the defenders side
they have to withstand the attackers
assault for three minutes so if they
protect the hostage for three minutes
and withstand the assaults the timer
goes to zero they win but keep in mind
as well the hostage can die so both
teams need to be careful where they have
their firefights and when they place
their briefs charges and other
explosions because whoever kills that
hostage they are they lose alright so
we're gonna be kicking things up on
Chris Henry's side he's gonna be leading
the charge first team Ravens shield
yeah it is the screen that you're gonna
be following and you will be hearing his
voice and it's coast captain max voices
Chris are you ready yeah Jen thank you
alright he's gonna be starting up on the
attackers side good luck have fun guys
fun all right guys you ready I don't
think yeah take this Salter Mac can you
pick up the appointment yeah I got it
alright let's stick to the backyard
spawn
let's get right into it let's do it all
right Mac I'm gonna set my drone to the
top floor can you take a look downstairs
I got it I need somebody to check out
the dining room and construction - I got
nobody the front door yet stairs is
clear master bedrooms good nobody there
I saw one downstairs I find a hostage
she's in the laundry room okay I got
nothing in construction I got one guy at
the top of the stairs oh I put a barbed
wire he's going towards the the bathroom
I'm coming downstairs now see a lotta
reinforcements in the basement and
garage okay yeah there's a hostage
laundry room I got a guy putting a
shield in the laundry room he's looking
towards the hostage they got the two
walls at the back stairs reinforced I
got one shield inside the gym is looking
towards the stairs from kitchen side
looks like they're setting up camp
I'm gonna keep my drone inside the gym
okay let's split up here jack Mac come
with me to the right-hand side I need
Chris and Carl come to the kitchen
window put a breach on it and and wait
for my cue keep an eye on the windows up
top there's one guy upstairs right
behind you
let's go through the dining room windows
I'll take the right window Mac and I got
the left some barricades yeah get out
before we go in there I got a hole in
the back door and kitchen off living the
most clear I'm in shock beginning can
you clear with the office good good okay
guys you can come in through kitchen
window keep an eye on the back door they
shot it out we got you covered though
okay good job trap back door back door
two down nice job he's down
there's to the ball on the stairs here
Mac yeah I'll take a Sheila front so
they're around okay let's go towards the
lounge
I think they blew up right above top
floor
Jacques stop knocks down you want four
good to take this slow Mac I got one
running towards the garage you didn't
get the guy upstairs I know I didn't get
it
thank you by the way can you keep an eye
on the flank yeah I'm gonna blow the
wall here
keep an eye there I got nothing back
that's clear like stairs is good I'm
gonna do the floor right here keep an
eye on the lobby got a minute
breaching got one down one down yeah I
gotta back up oh man you get me yeah I'm
getting you nice things we got 50
seconds I got pads though
take a peek down here you got 40 seconds
I'm jumping down okay right here got a
nice job reaching the objective room
wall oh that's another one nice we're
giving you nice work
30 seconds appreciative already yeah
ready grab the hostage yeah
let's try pushing forward we're good
we're good
keep going want to cover behind me yeah
I got you PLAs here plays there
back down to dogs down let's work by
nice work good job man
you drop the hostage yeah the husband
went down gonna have time to get her
back
all right so defending the stick to be
the master bedroom
okay I'm gonna go with the trapper and
set up inside the bathroom in the master
bedroom Mac you and I we're gonna go
towards the kid's room
I get the windows in there first once
we're done they were gonna go to
construction guys get one window keep
the one gets a barbed wire top of the
stairs drone on the hostage
okay we're all set up and take a peek
out the front back there spawning I'll
take a look on the right-hand side
nothing on the right head see him there
you go right there shooting at the
windows coming from front I have a
satchel charge I got to put on the door
coming from front door guys
let's check the cameras I see shadows
talk to those back inside the boys are
getting said the boys room I'm coming in
construction also can I get the door
yeah I can still got a guy in the window
don't but it's okay to get it let's go
back to the last bedroom one of the
lobby keep an eye on the use of cameras
I got two guys construction I tagged
them he said to point out in the hallway
yeah yeah don't worry about us come to
the hostage don't worry about us
shucks down I got a guy in closet 24
point man hostage flash I can't see man
I think we're going down brutal and then
we're gonna be back with six more rounds
of gameplay and this time it's gonna be
none scripted so all bets are off we
don't know who's gonna win I think it's
gonna be really exciting so basically
while the guys get set up for the next
match we're gonna be talking a little
bit so if let's start things off with
why we decided to make the decision to
go multiplayer first and how it affects
your life as a game designer in terms of
game design well for us going
multiplayer firstly I was a focus on the
player experience and the reactivity of
the play so it's 60 FPS you wanted to
really focus on player options because
multiplayer is very dynamic environment
and over the destruction and and you
want the player to have the Maximizer
their tools and their tactical options
so in a dynamic environment like
multiplayer they wanted the players to
focus on their gameplay and really make
it a tight tight player experience we
can translate to the rest of the modes
that you guys just saw a lot of
destruction in many ways such as reached
charges we had merely destroying
barricades and such why do we have
reigning vu destruction in Rainbow six
well Rainbow six has always been about
the living out a fantasy as a Counter
Terrorist unit and Counter Terrorist
units they are destruction experts right
so in previous games been breaching
clear is the quintessential rainbow move
you go up to a door you stack up and
then you blow a breach charge and then
you go in so we wanted to take that
aspect when we started to see each we
wanted to take that and kind of stress
that so no longer use breaching against
the door you can breach walls floor
different areas making sure that you get
the drop on the enemy and you can take
out the enemy and get the hostage and
save some lives so again we're going
we're going are staying true to that
counter terrorist unit fantasy of you
know being surgical with destruction and
while using the instruction we have to
be real careful because we only have one
life in this game-mode no respawn how
does it come into play in game design
same game design so when we were
iterating on the hostage rescue
game-mode we didn't we experimented a
lot of things so we did I did respawn we
did one life and and a bunch of
ingredients in the game-mode and we
really found that no respawn what it
brings to or brings to the game-mode is
you every single choice you make is mean
something right so an every single life
matters so your teammates matter their
paramount right so as you just saw in
the gameplay session when it says when
it goes 5 2 4 5 vs. 4 5 5 vs. 3 you can
I get more the team that's losing it
ramps up attention you have to re
rediscover what the environment and make
new tactical choices and then and on the
other side you know if you guys are the
ones you know and don't have the damage
and making the kills your tactics are
working and your unit being uniform so
going back to that Rainbow six fantasy
of being a counter-terrorist unit and
working together alright so it seems
like the guys are ready remember guys
you from a twitch chat that we will be
doing a giveaway and that's we're going
to be answering questions soon so make
sure to send your questions at us at
hashtag Rainbow six live we will be
pulling them from there and you're gonna
be able to win some sweet sweet prizes
so basically now we're gonna be headed
into our unscripted match where all bets
are off and we're gonna be seeing which
team from e3 because those were to e3
teams that we're fighting enough for
three days which team is gonna be
victorious is gonna get the bragging
rights forever and the eternal glory so
basically right now we're gonna have
team Raven shield led by Chris Henry and
on the other side we have team rogue
spear led by Adam Crawley we're going to
be starting things up on Chris Henry's
side once again that's his screen you're
gonna be following for the first three
rounds then we're gonna take a little
intermission we're going to
answer your questions and then we're
gonna be playing three more rounds to
see who is victorious are you guys ready
yeah Jim thank you all right good luck
have fun guys okay guys so this is gonna
be a little bit tougher we got to slow
it down just a tad let's stick to the
first spawn here and through the
hostages we're gonna switch it if based
on where she is
I'm gonna do the same thing no McIndoe
go go upstairs can your head to dining
room I need somebody in the construction
I see a window already being done yeah
Construction Set this machine I'm gonna
go right to construction but I guess
spit out your drums - yeah I got
construction I know one wall not
reinforcements hallway by construction
there's two guys on the first floor
right now yeah switch switch response
which is fun everybody stay together go
to the right-hand side I got a guy in
the bathroom is the bathroom okay I got
a guy in the bathroom he's leaving now
he's getting the door to the bathroom
from the stairwell there's two of them
in the first floor right now so I'll be
careful
okay stick to the right stick to the
right-hand side I say behind the cover
don't let them see you
you said there was a guy in boy's room
okay we're gonna go across up onto the
balcony wait right by you dock right off
yeah
Chuck I'm gonna peek through here first
kitchen looks good
gotta go up top yeah see there's up
there in construction be positive okay
go into master bedroom I got it
okay I'm coming with you guys where's
where's the nitrous L bathroom
where is it though I don't hear it
towards bathroom
careful Jacques there's a guy in Atlanta
like a construction cover
nice job nice nice job Jacques master
bedroom is down is it clear
yeah a touch by the guy inside the
construction he's in construction man
where's where's this I've reached the
wall looking towards construction got a
minute 15 full room okay what side of
the pool room I'm gonna go back outside
moving up back stairs
it's to v3
I'm down not back stairs main stairs
it's just it's just you Mak it's just
you you got 25 seconds whose main stairs
coming up kitchen kitchen kitchen is
something I love you oh man man could
try we have two nitrous cells there they
had a lotta stuff yeah weird see 42
so what 0 for them yeah
okay guys we're gonna go to our bread
and butter
I'm gonna go trapper let's stick to the
the top all right first one ready do it
gonna sit up get some farm boy okay I
got some barbed wire back stairs
keep an eye the the back of the front
sponsor this father like it yeah me too
I don't see no not a front not up front
I'm Mac I'm right behind you then okay
let's move up with that to cornered Jeff
what a bay windows I don't hear anything
I don't hear any repel okay good good
I'll show you the cameras yeah I got one
at the front construction
yeah they're coming yeah I'm cornered
inside nice work
I got he's down I'm pinned down in the
boys room yeah I'm playing nice work for
to coming back into bathroom this one
kid's room nice work jack cover me and
go to check cameras he's on the back
stairs i stock stairs yeah
a chicken kitchen anyway he's going down
the back stairs little same construction
construction balcony had Fred I can you
front closer to the bathroom bathroom
balcony yeah nice work guys
[Music]
nice job nice calls man that had good
views from the cameras there so one one
yeah all right guys let's finish it up
here clean it up
okay I'm gonna go with the assaulter
again okay you ready yeah sim deal Mack
I'll head upstairs
check-check dining I'll check dining I
need something go downstairs to get me
going downstairs recently I got nothing
front door my spread was good dining is
cool basement
I'm gonna keep my drone top floor
actually look at the keep an eye out for
rumors like these the holes in the walls
to watch out
probably have a shot down
let's switch our spawn same field as we
did in the first round their right-hand
side
I got one guy construction he's doing
all this construction he's peeking out
the construction window go right
hand-side ran inside
same deal yeah Zaki got it
take a peek up through dining room
windows
they got all the doors garage doors
kitchen gives room back its room okay
Jacques go all the way up that's two in
a gym then they're coming up
yeah it'll guy in the gym and one guy is
in the kitchen right now Bobby it's
going hey sounds nice job Chuck okay
hold on I'm just checking out master
bedroom I got one in master bedroom
what was that much name was a team kill
there I got him down he's in the dirt
where is this where's this happening
guys I don't see anybody
Elson hold on I got it I gotta use
another drone nice job two-on-one
we got a minute go slow go slow checking
out lounge
yeah Lounge is good come to me inside
Jim just above Jim it's probably closer
to hostage so much is slow yeah yeah you
know what come with me come with me are
you pointment okay yeah don't call yeah
45 seconds let me find him right behind
the wall there under the stairs okay
hold on we got 20 seconds car start
moving up start moving up nice nice job
what happened nice kill each other nice
good work man good work
all right well slave guys seems like
team Raven shield is gonna be in the
lead going up in these next three rounds
that we're gonna be playing a right
after this short intermission that we
have planned because now is the time
where you answer your questions that
you've been tweeting at us all along so
I have them there we're gonna be
answering them
but first while the guys get set up
Andrew do you have a little disclaimer
for us yeah so we have a lot of
questions we are about single-player and
co-op modes I know you guys and we know
that you know fan favorite is Tara Hunt
we're working very hard on a non
single-player and co-op modes across the
board and we know you guys want more
information on it we're gonna we still
gonna keep it in the oven a little bit
longer and work on it some more
we're a pre-alpha right now as we get to
alpha when it's ready we'll expose it to
the world and show you guys what we have
upper sleeves it'll be worth it so stick
with us there
promise you we have under the table as
is good so yeah stick with let's keep
posting the forums we're listening but
uh stay tuned alright so we're gonna be
having three roller rounds right after
these questions so stay tuned for more
action and to know which team is gonna
be victorious forever and ever
so let's get started our first question
is from cricket is beast how dynamic is
the destruction element and how can one
breach a building without explosives so
as you saw in the other like well it's a
procedural base destruction system so
it's by material so now you saw that
wooden planks and the barricades they go
down with melee hits so it essentially
it's gonna be by material right so if
you see wood you know that I wouldn't
2x4 for example you can break it with a
with the melee hit and and that's how
you can like push forward so anything
that's a it's logical and and comprised
of wood will break just like what will
it depends on like how dense it is and
stuff like that so for JYP's
you know that if you may Lea JYP's wall
you know you'll probably make a small
hole but there's many layers to a
drywall in a house so you want me to do
a full hole there so again you want to
put explosive on that as you see in the
demo so yeah it's going to be it's if
they have the right tool for the right
material so a question from X King X
nightmare
as old school are six vet from many
hundreds of hour of Raven shield how
would you compare gameplay to rainbow
Vegas I don't know I've seen it's
rainbow siege so I'm a massive Raven
shield fan as well and personally what
we're taking from Raven shield gameplay
is hard decisions so remember you know
playing Raven shield when I was younger
you didn't make a lot of hard decisions
whenever you're in game of where your
team's gonna go you know II to scout out
the area cuz you'll be punished for not
scouting and not executing your plan and
observing the right way so we're really
trying to take this and first the first
and foremost we're putting it in the
multiplayer but we're gonna try and
harness this in the single-player and
co-op modes as well so that siege is a
throwback to those hard decision-making
moments where you care about what your
team is doing and you
and you the benefits and consequences of
your plan and execution a question from
Michael Morgan senior yeah what happened
to Rainbow six Patriots Rainbow six
Patriots was was cancelled and we rebid
the project which is now Rainbow six
siege so if you're looking right now the
net or the next
Rainbow six is Rainbow six siege sort of
from the reboot was born this project
and we iterated constantly so Patriots
is cancelled is now Rainbow six siege
question from John Swift how would you
describe the new shooting system is it
closer in line to the legacy of the
series or is it being changed or updated
to fall in live in line with today's
shooters a good question so I would say
we're doing a bit of both
so we want to be true to the previous
gameplay of old-school Rainbow six games
where it's not a you know it's it's you
to take your time with your shots and to
focus on accuracy that being said
shooters have come a long way since the
original first-person
Rainbow six games so we want to make
sure we're current with with the
advances have been made in the shooter
genre so we're kind of do it I trying to
satisfy both we're trying to make sure
that we're gonna take relevant fun
shooting but also acknowledge the
previous hallmark aspects of the rainbow
series question from Koenigsegg so ps4
PC Xbox one all of them so Rainbow six
siege will be on ps4 piece PC and Xbox
one
a question from Elmo the brave how why
the variety of weapons and gadgets are
there you see a few of them right now in
the attacking side you see breached
charges and the flat stun grenade the
for the flashbang and frag grenade as
well we have in there so we're gonna
make the gadgets diverse and applicable
to both attack and defense so that we
have defended gadgets or all about you
know trapping and protecting and things
like that in building that stronghold
and on the attacking side making sure
all of our gadgets are diverse in terms
of breaching and observing and also you
know crowd control flashing up flashing
enemy and clearing rooms so or make it
as ever
as possible and it's a rainbow game guns
are always a big part of Rainbow six I
want to make sure that we have a lot of
gun options so we have SMGs and their
pistols assault rifles and you know you
might see some some throwbacks in there
and in the near future we're gonna be
taking two more questions we have one
from attack Mack what's the reason for
barricades barricading is part of the
the the siege so on windows and windows
and doorways to kind of really reroute
the attackers and have them kind of
second-guess whether or not they want to
go in or they want to waste you know
throw a breach charge on there mainly it
give the making the attackers think
twice and reroute them so block some
access really kind of hinder their
progress as they go on so the more
barricades the longer it's gonna take
for them to actually get to the
objective room and they might want to go
someplace else and find a more
accessible way where you could be
waiting lying in wait - you know trap
them and ambush them so it's all about
routing your enemy and making them think
twice will they break through but that
being said they can also breach and
clear the classic move so it's you want
to reroute the enemy but the same time
there's some pros and cons to it if
depending on how you execute your
tactics question from frevo no recoil in
the weapons or a pre-alpha right now so
the recoil you're seeing in the game is
not final by any means
that's the g36c and the mp5 in there
right now
so the recoil is not a hundred percent
yet we're gonna wear a pre-alpha as
we're striving towards more we're
hearing you guys on the feedback of the
weapons you know making each one feel
like they actually does in real life and
operate in an operating that way so
realistic recoil and bullet spread and
stuff so yes keep keep with us we're out
we're gonna be updating a as we get to
alpha and keep on going so stick with us
the weapons will be evolving as the game
evolves as well seems like the players
are ready but before we start just a
little reminder to make sure that you
stay tuned to see if you won the contest
and won the sweet sweet gear so just
look up on Twitter we're gonna hit you
up from there Rainbow six Twitter and
while I'm at it make sure to follow it
at Rainbow six games alright so we're
gonna be headed into part two of our
gameplay session I would like to remind
you that we have no script so both teams
are in it to win it for eternal glory
Fame and bragging rights we're gonna be
playing three more rounds this time
we're gonna be following Adam Crawley
from Team Raven shield nope something
wrong Spears yes and he's gonna be
trying to see if he can bring it back
because right now we are at a score of
two to one for team Raven shield with
Chris Henry good luck Adam are you ready
yes I am thanks let's get to it guys all
right guys keep the communication tight
and let's just you know keep doing what
we're doing but little harder it's not
gonna be more wins I'm gonna go sell
through Steve you take the point Matt
okay and Alan you go on be sure yeah i'm
britta right and let's go for the back
Harris pond
[Music]
the ground ball
I'll check up the top flat savvy off
spaceman
I don't see any tougher and I hope
anything in the dining room over I guess
the basement I go okay I'm gonna go down
through the gym then died back in back
conditions this guy barricading into the
gym reinforce the walls in the gym as
well what's the first boss let's go
let's go for it first of all from that
garage to the late 9th Street ascension
students really like that bother
so they're not reinforcing the wall
through from the gym to the laundry room
Alan Steve you wanna come with me just
follow me and fast and so I'm just look
around the back okay don't go through
yes it's it's really a still pokéballs
rainforest they have the doors
barricaded suit
okay we're just gonna go into the pool
my packet
frickin for Johnny don't do the floor
each yeah go ahead and do it pound down
yeah there's actually guys go ahead
reach every drink yeah he's in the car I
got stuck in the high 33
do we get Mac now he's back Stevie no
okay
I think Kris just moving down the back
stairs hang on hang on okay wait grunts
there kalindra there's a guy in the
garage - she'll come
wait room now right below you in time
he's watching for you doctor don't do it
he's watching he's watching there's a
guy come back stairs as well I'm done
with that just keep on to camp guys
don't see anyone on the cameras can't
help you all right 45 seconds Trey all
right three one with one the next two
from one side up yeah
[Music]
okay so we're attacking again now now
we're depending what we doing are we
defending yeah
let's go with what's gonna get the error
graduals
love what wiring back stairs
get the doors for the trio's bass trying
to get out over the ground-level floor
somebody watching spawns - okay
answer cameras was that kids bedroom
yeah real is getting a basement I want
to say it out for and watch cams Steve
take cover don't see unknown on the
cameras is the guy the master bedroom
thing I thank you
oh [ __ ] they're watching
oh my god there's a guy bathroom master
yeah they're watching me the drones they
came into the bathroom and there's a guy
the front balcony to what you have the
bathroom back off back off try it
yourself you have it
we access your camera's the gym ceiling
sorry breach the ceiling of the gym no
no kiss briefs Oh
let's go me geez hey just drop in the
gym
I'm just two of them in the gym watch
out - came down the back stairs
Steve shoot some holes
see there's the breach yeah hey let's
try to get one more guys yeah at least
one attacked last round
okay point man again Steve okay I'll go
check out the ground floor again
[Music]
[Applause]
nicest guys so it's not the master
bedroom now obviously it touch the
dining dining room
[Music]
hello in the wall across from - into
construction
I'll leave my drone and the kitchen this
guy in the back stairs
let's do front
we'll take the the front balcony cares
and no look on my drone it's coming
through the top floor actually Anton
take front parking you and I will do the
repel on the side okay okay so follow me
Steve go with with Anton watch out
windows set the bedroom window
and some start let me know when you're
gonna start push for pressure and then
and then Alan will start moving my
throat you know try to get something
there's actually a guy right - it as
well so you gotta gosh
I think chatter crash
okay Allen let's just go gummy through
the wound window through the matter yeah
he's on the right-hand side
yes I can't see him yeah alright okay
I'm coming up guys just wait up wait for
Chris is down got one tell Falcone oh
guy in the bathroom he's gonna come with
the back stairs did I say bathroom in
basement the last one on the front
balcony as well yeah okay this guy
anything officer anything Oh front lobby
well try to get them all or reviving
yeah
okay to the kitchen how that I just saw
him in my lucky
Wow congratulations to team Chris Hendry
you guys did it you win eternal glory
and fame sorry Adam better luck next
time
it was a good try though alright so
we're gonna be closing things off thank
you guys so much for checking out our
livestream we hope you enjoyed the
livestream play and ruiny last words i
think that's yeah thanks a lot for
coming up for watching our pre-alpha
gameplay or our premier footage on us on
Twitch um please keep keep talking to us
you know go on the forums only you be
forms in the Rainbow six siege forms
keep telling us what you want we have
our ear to the ground or listen what the
community has to say and what you guys
can say you know about the session we
guys are one from different modes all
that still like good stuff well we're
listening so thanks for stopping by and
uh yeah we're gonna be reshipping
sometime in 2015 for next-gen consoles
and PC thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to tweet at us at
Rainbow six game and follow us follow us
on facebook facebook.com slash Rainbow
six and we're gonna be listening to you
guys and reading everything you have to
say we're really excited about it and we
hope to see you soon we hope to be
bringing to you guys more content I'd
like to thank you Andrew as well I'm
sure all the players today thank you
guys so much to you guys soon
[Music]